how's it going bros my welcome welcome
welcome welcome well to goat MMO
simulator massive manly ovaries dammit
every time we played as the hunter we
played as the microwave I kinda wanna do
the rogue let's do the rogue a precise
fashion at just the right place and
finishing off with a rich lipstick
jaysis guys every time so now I am a
rogue alright let's test out our new
abilities under dummies the damage of
course we try the goats alright number
one just one oh my god I can stealth
daddy so [ __ ] god I want to trade a
stick of spam for you slice of cheese oh
my god how do I write to him blob blob
trade me damnit what it's already within
alright let's try that
alright we go into stealth they don't
see me and they don't hear me cuz I'm a
rogue and then yes yes yes oh yes this
is my new favorite oh yes yes yeah
oh I think I made a baby let's go out in
the land of the free and do some quest
front flip brent flip Oh nailed it I
like my boots their product oh there's
the beach all right you know what let's
go to the beach and do the mermaid quest
cuz we haven't done that and I don't I
don't know let's teleport Oh what all
right I got a genius idea let's use the
wheel to go there yes yeah maybe not a
good idea
damn it help help
alright will you're coming with me can I
lick it ah I did I did
alright bad idea oh here's the beach
awesome glory gobbler Gold Beach my
favorite place in the whole world oh oh
god the murlocs oh gosh get me Rhonda
there oh it's mom
alright many use a staff coat ability
it's not really working at all is it I
don't see the point really
but we stand her yes
stealth stealth stunts in the ass I mean
that's undid weird we got me around to
the mermen Miranda the ugly mermaid the
ugliest mermaid this town damn it don't
fight it Miranda Miranda
damn it Miranda yeah what is he doing
what what must try now let's try this it
looks amazing
oh hello it doesn't work why does any
work hello hello zombie killer get away
are you kidding me it's stopped working
what stop it damn it damn it
alright you know what [ __ ] it are you
kidding me oh god damn it
are you [ __ ] it pieces all right [ __ ]
ah
you piece of [ __ ] mermaid there's so
many mermaids they're so pretty
I better self and kill them alright
let's go back and give her the mermaid
what the [ __ ] is he doing is he throwing
money make it rain make it rain make it
rain on them house yeah alright there
must be some way can we yes yes gosh
break it I hear it raining Oh God
rich dude are you the Burger King man
even in death he makes it rain what a
true hero
I'll never forget you rich man I don't
know what the purpose of me doing that
was but it made my nipples erect and
that's all that really matters in life
remember that kids what are you doing
the out is out damn it what are you what
are you doing that's not how you fish
Mac I keep telling you every day I keep
like how I don't want to go down the
waterfall now what you gotta do
something I'll go get you help I'll go
get help I go get ya stupid idiot I'm
not gonna help him oh god no oh no it's
happening I'm fine now
all right I'll help you I'll help you
hang on buddy I got you oh that was that
was a close one wasn't he ah no no no
now I love you don't die nice to fact
anyway oh no it oh well we're all gonna
die one way or another all right what do
we got in here that's too quick
oh yeah it's in here I took this it's
like there we go
true love conquers all I think she came
she's so satisfied stunning never works
man oh I don't know what happened
I'm gonna go back to the mermaid place I
[ __ ] love that place fried Flay
when will I apply makeup on people I
don't understand god damn I love this
game man it's so much fun to just [ __ ]
around servant hello 7:00 you make quest
oh my gee coach I am deciding need of
you I'm in dire need of your assistance
you see my master my very rich master
he's sort of a situation yeah he's he's
[ __ ] dead I killed him did I mention
he's really really rich yeah I saw that
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] rich all right there
you go there's your rich man maybe
they're rich Oh Jason I level up here's
half of the reward you really didn't
have to knock him unconscious he's fine
I think I got money
whoa Nelly metal Alaka Mira Lackey I
stand that I can't say that sounded
longer you you getting it out of here
you kill them kill as many as possible
and take their take their eyes what the
[ __ ] why they're lifeless evil staring
eyes just make the sound stop please I
don't think their sound is coming out of
their eyes and if they do it is it
sounds [ __ ] awesome I'm sorry I
mermaids you're ugly and the rule
applies that everything ugly has to die
I didn't came up with it I don't
necessarily like it but you would all
have today thank you thank you very much
how do I get their eyes there it is they
drop one of the eye
Jesus how are they so big there we go
five fish eyes thank you thank you very
much
hey why are you holding five yeah dad
that's disgusting here take this reward
and never to come near me again you
crazy person what's my reward a bucket
it gives me a [ __ ] bucket and calls
me crazy do you know how much they're
worth I'm gonna sell that [ __ ] on eBay
I'm [ __ ] rich ex slow pants adventure
eh you look mighty brave a lot more sir
than myself well I don't know you're
wearing a pretty [ __ ] ugly outfit I'm
afraid I'm now a worrier and there's a
whole lot of danger between me and this
town do you think you could help me get
there safely
sure why not
what do you want me to do them where are
you going
do you have to walk so [ __ ] slow are
you [ __ ] kidding me
Jesus Christ get on with it
alright where do you want to go all
right Ringo tire slope pants come on
wake up
Mike slope pants were here Jesus Christ
oh my god oh my god he's so slow oh my
god ah there it is you can do it you can
do it come on go already damning cute
thank you thank you thanks so many
quests Simon adventures where should we
go next friend flip
there was the one other question Beach
we should do that what is it with this
horse like what do you want from me it
goes what is coming there's coming it's
coming
got you now [ __ ] take me to the next
dimension oh god oh god what is
happening help what where am i where am
i with it I'm outside the game I don't
think this is supposed to happen country
forever dude damn it human rogue and
he's the goat and he's even a hunter
what the [ __ ] hypocrite goats these days
he's touching her boobs and he's making
it rain what a truly perfect Copper
Queen blog
oh hello Queen blog what can I do for
you Queen blog it is I yes of course I
will lick your anus I mean I will save
the queen I need 210 gullible what what
does that mean what the [ __ ] is that do
you see that is it giant mermaid [ __ ]
they're smelling their genitals how
wonderful Oh what the [ __ ] is this
assistant dwarven village nice the mines
oh my god are they frogs what are they
you guys oh sorry Bilbo Baggins watch it
you're not fooling anyone you're a go it
what the [ __ ] am i doing down here Here
I am so confused oh my god the golden
wagon wheel I better bring it to myself
Bjorn Heitor a beyond hater oh here's a
beyond hater oh and I'm so slow
I really really hate these beers I hate
them so much
go kill ten beers alright Bjorn Hajduk
oh no oh no it's it's beyond it's oh my
god it's it's it's a Swedish your
friends I don't you used to be in a kids
show
dammit I can't I'm sorry Bjorn I'm so
sorry I have to murder well there's so
many of them [ __ ] it there we go ten
bears are dead
thank you that will be $69.99 sure know
how to kill stuff well I am a goat rogue
after all I am a goat alright let's go
into here in the next episode but for
now thank you for watching brothers
leave a like if you enjoyed and as
always I'll see you in the next one stay
awesome bruh